les APIs sont de retour à plaisir depuis
2001 les animations au pied des
immeubles sont devenu une tradition dans
la commune avec le retour du beauemps
cette édition remporte déjà un franc
succès aujourd'hui c'est le lancement de
ces API 2016 qui pour nous pour les
maisons des familles est un moment fort
de l'année
puisque nous rencontrons beaucoup de
plaisiroir et le but étant aussi de que
les gens se rencontrent et forment du
lien entre eux un véritable temps fort à
partager en famille et entre voisins
cette année la thématique s'est donc
portée sur le vivre ensemble le vivre
ensemble c'est bah au quotidien toute
l'année tout d'abord au sein des maisons
des familles et aussi au sein de la
commune donc c'est une thématique qui a
été choisie par l'ensemble des
partenaires et qui a été choisie je
dirais assez naturellement cette année
structure gonflable atelier maquillage
et coloriage ou encore jeux de société
ici les activités de ne manque pas pour
occuper petits et grands ça fait plaisir
aux enfants qui en profitent ça se voit
et puis pour les parents aussi de de
mettre en premier pas pour les grandes
vacances qui vont qui vont pas tarder
j'ai joué au château gonamp avec mes
copains on a mangé après on est parti
faire une petite promenade en vélo après
moi j'ai bien aimé c'était bien
moi je trouve ça génial c'est vrai qu'il
faudrait que ça soit un peu plus souvent
parce que pour les enfants c'est
vraiment une opportunité de rencontrer
les uns et les autres comme pour les
mamans et ça les ouvre à d'autres jeux
d'autres d'autres univers les APIs c'est
toute la semaine de 16h30 à 19h un
goûtter de clôture est prévu pour ce
vendredi à la Maison des familles de la
mosaïque